[Music]
all right this one's going to be this
one's going to be kind of long
but you need every one of these details
in order to formulate your opinion okay
i'm taking you down the road
but he's always going to throw a curve
ball at the end though and i'm gonna
bite on everything so watch your
homophobic things and all that stuff
wait till the end
1999 okay these two teen girls
they uh it's in alabama sounds like a
porno chappelle's already worried bro
sadly
two teen girls in alabama they're shot
and left in the trunk of their oh that's
not a porno
joke something is a porno to somebody
two wait did you say teen like under 18
or 19 17 oh i thought i thought you said
19
1999
let's uh just take it from the top guys
steve's like get me out of here
[Laughter]
i thought it was 19 year olds in 1999
i'm glad you quit drugs a decade ago
steve's already like can we edit me out
of the video again i know okay it's in
pre-2000 at the turn of the millennium
oh these two teen girls
alabama found shot dead in the trunk of
their own car
oh their own car no murderer was caught
right
and then in 2015 this woman named rina
crum comes out who used to work for the
police department and she claims the
police covered that murder up and they
were involved somehow
2015 right okay whoa true crime podcasts
and blogs go crazy over this info
there's all these theories about how the
cops do this cops with that
super super popular uh murder that
everyone starts analyzing
and then in 2019
through uh
through dna the same dna that they found
the uh the same like uh dna technique
that they used to find the golden state
killers
they were able to find
a match for the dna here in 2019 and
it's some alabama truck drivers and it's
20 years perfectly later wow
but
this truck driver his defense lawyers
are like we got to get you off we think
we can get this rina crumb lady's info
and get her dad or her insider info to
get you
exonerated yeah because well he's not in
jail yet but they're like we need to use
that as our defense because this lady
knows something about the cops yeah and
the cover-up theory right so his defense
team meets with reena crum and they're
like tell us everything you know we got
to get this guy off the hook if you know
who really did this and you know the
cops were involved and everything they
start questioning her to get that
evidence out she starts saying i i just
can't remember i don't recall it was a
long time ago
eventually she says she just made that
whole [ __ ] thing up
wow
there never was a crooked cop involved
there never was data that she knew she
just that should be [ __ ] yeah she
could go to jail for that they should
put her in the trunk dude [ __ ] shoot
her ass yeah all right bart hey i
thought we were over we just said give
her some time dude i thought we were
done
how did you learn wait to another
episode
yeah well i was like i used to think i
used to think you shouldn't put a woman
in the trunk of shooter
now i do i definitely do hey that's my
seventh day at venice
that's his offshoot bart
yeah swans at it again
that's burt swan
but here's here's the little uh caveat
though is that these same uh like crime
blog people and and analysts you know
they think that
the cops were hushing her up amazing and
that it's they got to her yeah they
think they got to her they're like we
already released 12 episodes on this
series so we got to keep going so we're
knuckle deep we got to add to the end of
the year sold already even the truck
drivers defense team is saying that the
cops hushed her up somehow
because they're just falling without
walking
the case
what was her title again she's a uh she
was a regular person yeah she worked at
a police station okay so she's in there
she's in the field in the system yeah at
the time she's adjacent she's a window
washer at the police station
which maybe that was made up too i don't
know
that is very awkward though for like
somebody to be associated in or working
uh with the police then to say that and
then when something actually goes down
to be like nah
like
wha what would be a an incentive if it
wasn't a hush she hated it
i think she hated someone in the station
and then she wanted to get him in
trouble people take credit for crimes
that had nothing to do with all the
[ __ ] time
it's a weird thing yeah
like bart knows those cops people just
[ __ ] call and they go like i did it i
am the [ __ ] river city killer and
then
i mean even uh look at d.b cooper you
know how many people claimed they were
davey cooper the guy that did the famous
plane heist yeah and they never found
them because it's like because it's a
cool thing and they talk about it all
the time or whatever
and imagine imagine if you're if you're
just somebody that's watching like a
crime blog or like a bunch of these like
podcasts and you think oh man let me try
to contribute something and maybe i'll
be like the savior dude
a bunch of dudes tried to come out and
say they killed tupac remember that
there was like a bunch of different
people who like no no i did it that
guy's a [ __ ] liar i [ __ ] killed
tupac like it's like whoa bro
that's so weird it's weird it's like
everyone think everyone comes out and
says they're satoshi
yeah oh yeah i'm satoshi you know what
about the dna match they yeah what was
that yeah because they found dna from
the trucker right yeah what was the
truckers come doing
on one of the girls in her bra yeah this
is where the porno comes back in
yeah that's that's where the bra comes
back
yeah so that's why the defense team was
so desperate to get this woman's
testimony because they were like
everything else was like it's this guy's
going to go to jail but but but as a
defense team how do you argue dna
there's like the dna
like i don't even know the cover you
have to create the story of why the dna
was there yeah because if they have to
follow someone else's testimony then
they can kind of reverse injury so what
was this truck driver doing with 17
euros well let's just say that if the if
it was planted dude if it was yeah
exactly if it was a crooked cop thing
within the elements of this story then
they can argue that the evidence was
planted oh like the homie from wisconsin
yeah dude i was just about to say that
stephen stephen
yesterday yeah i think what happened
what happened on that one well the main
thing that the main defense for stephen
avery is that the police department
hated him so they try to plant evidence
on
on the uh season one and i was like oh
man and then season two apparently it's
a 180.
season two 180s
that's probably what the defense was
looking for they were looking for
something like well because all you
really need to do is prove to the jurors
right
if you get the jury arguing enough i
mean maybe you'll get a [ __ ] mistrial
who knows but then like or deadlocked
jerk but then the main thing is is that
without a shadow of a doubt this guy has
to be guilty
so if you have that doubt that rina crum
had
she was sitting on some real estate it's
crazy how like there's a lot of these
things that are popping up now that like
dna can be tracked and like the science
and the technology has come right like
we've done like probably two or three
articles similar to this now right a
case from the 80s the cold case from the
50s a random [ __ ] thing that was
buried right and through d they're
arresting dudes in their 90s from
murders that they did when they were
[ __ ] teenagers they're somehow still
arresting nazi prison guards and i'm
like when are those guys just going to
be [ __ ] dead
are they still alive how are they still
alive what is going on they're thriving
huh yeah
they're like i made it out
those guys are like we eat chia seeds
every morning
yeah what's your routine dude i'm in
grass shock
meditate for two hours a day
yeah
yeah
man
damn
what are we saying about the dna stuff
no no
just saying like it's not gonna be like
the [ __ ] last one we're probably
gonna keep on as technology progresses
we're gonna be solving [ __ ] cold
cases from literally the 1900s
but as this cold case stuff grows in
popularity we're gonna get a lot of fake
[ __ ] evidence of people saying that
like oh i know about this i know about
that see that's that's the [ __ ] that's
annoying when you get these other
[ __ ] saying some [ __ ] yeah i
think they should be charged for the
crime that they say they were involved
in
just because it's like hey you wanted
that [ __ ] bad all right you get the
destination you're the killer yeah i did
not see that coming from you yeah nope
oh did i surprise you
do you feel like at this point though
like uh with the technology like that
because like even those dna things it's
not just a matter of like um getting
somebody's dna it's also a matter of
having like the data of like a dna pool
of people in order to cross-reference
things right at this point are you are
they not just going into like you know
institutions or penitentiaries or like
prisons and stuff like that and just
getting dna samples from everybody in
order to like build their databases well
if you've been arrested you already have
you already already have it right one of
the scariest things though about dna
evidence is the way that it makes
a jury like so sure that someone is
guilty
so you can plant dna evidence which has
happened many many many many times right
yeah and then the jury is just like
absolutely guilty no question about it
we don't even want to [ __ ] hear from
you really yeah i could have farted at
the movie theater where there was a
murder at and then they could have
[ __ ]
caught my [ __ ] crop dusting that's
one hell that's one hell of a fart
no joe's farts are quick could have
farted on a freshly dead body yeah and
they think i killed the guy right
they'll be like why is there joe
reminisces of joe on his [ __ ] shirt
wait you said they caught the golden
state killer by 23andme yeah i guess
they got a piece of evidence what he did
he did 23 and me was like no it wasn't
him oh i thought
[Laughter]
but apparently it's through relative so
be yeah so when you put in your dna
to these [ __ ] apps they they'll
connect you with people that have
similar dna to you
and oh you're like oh this is your
relative so i think one of the people
pat and oswalt's wife apparently was the
one that found she was investigating a
case she found like a cigarette butt
with apparently some dna on it
was able to use that
extract the
evidence from there put it into the
database send it out to them and they
were able to connect through their
relatives that like oh this is the guy
and that's what that's how they found
out and he was a cop because he didn't
have his dna he was a system yeah yeah
he was a cop the whole time yeah that's
the problem is if you if you're not a
felon your dna is not in the files then
it's harder to like catch you because
you have no priors
but that's how they did it the cop was
the golden
dp killer but he went all the way from
the [ __ ] nord cow all the way to
socal bro that guy was like on a tour
yeah damn he's like the guy that like
sparked up [ __ ] rich ramirez that's
what people say he's like what's up los
angeles
[Laughter]
you